nouveau numéro de la voie est libre
françois rebsamen je vous ai vu hyper
attentif là sur le foot comme d'habitude
vous avez envie qu'elle revienne en
ligue 1 cette équipe oui comme tous les
supporters aient voulu en donner les
moyens ou comment ça se passait aux mots
c'est pas votre affaire
je pense que on a un bon président de du
club il veut d'abord équilibrer les
comptes et il a raison donc c'était
aussi un bon gestionnaire et un bon
entraîneur et un bon groupe est ce que
ça sera suffisant j'en sais rien en
football on sait jamais bon tout le cas
oui ça serait bien pour pour tous les
supporters et puis vu qu'on va
construire la nouvelle tribune très bien
allez on revient sur une question -
moines moins drôle j'allais dire mais
très importante celle de l'emploi
visiblement très importante pour les
habitants on m'a sélectionné deux
d'entre eux qui ont choisi de vous poser
une question à ce sujet
ça va me dire c'est que ferez vous pour
les chômeurs jeunes et vieux puisque la
courbe va diminuer mais elle est
toujours là donc il va sûrement
augmenter la fin de l'année pour ceux
qui ne travaillent pas sur dijon qu'est
ce que vous allez faire bonjour
rationnaires j'aimerais savoir quelle
est votre politique au niveau de
l'emploi des jeunes en bourgogne alors
pour l'instant on est dans merde dit
j'aurais pas président de la bourgogne
mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour répondre à ces d'abord chez ces
personnes j'ai donné des chiffres qui
sont plutôt encourageants donc c'est
vrai que nous avons une politique
volontariste regrette que le conseil
général ne se met pas aussi pour
remettre le pied à l'étrier à des jeunes
à travers les contrats d'avenir donc on
en a fait en dix on en a fait à la ville
c'est important parce que laisser ces
jeunes traîner loin de toute formation
il faut absolument leur redonner espoir
s'est fait à travers les contrats
d'avenir et puis contrairement à ce
qu'ont dit les contrats de génération ça
marche bien vous savez un tuteur un
jeune dans l'entreprise avec une aide
c'est vrai qu'on est sur le cadre
d'emplois aidés mais c'est pas nouveau
les emplois aidés mais ça ça ait de ça
redonne du pouvoir d'achat des familles
ça ça facilite l'activité et puis moi je
soutiens une entreprise je reçois les
tous les chefs d'entreprise qui me le
demandent dans les 24 heures j'essaie de
voir avec eux leurs plans de charge
leurs difficultés
d accompagner de déposer des lois qui
facilite l'obtention de brevets ou de la
mise à disposition sur le marché par
exemple a vécu hugo je me bats depuis un
an pour leur permettre d'accéder au
marché français donc voilà je suis à
leurs côtés et nous on leur facilite
l'environnement savez c'est ça qui
compte pour les entreprises
l'environnement c'est quoi c'est la
qualité de la vie pour faire venir des
salariés il faut souvent avoir une ville
attractive où les enfants des salariés
peuvent faire des études d'avoir des
conditions d'accueil d'écoles de crèches
on fait tout ça tout l'environnement
pour cette belle ville pour des
entreprises pour une entreprise qui
marche il ya des entreprises qui ne
marchent à des gens essilor ça marche
hugo ça marche place tôt ça marche donc
je pourrais en citer plein donc on est à
leur côté on croirait que les gens ne
savent pas qu'il ya des entreprises qui
marchent à dijon c'est vrai il ya aussi
des entreprises en difficulté et donc on
essaie et puis j'essaie d'implanter des
entreprises permettent de développer des
technopôles et à celui de grenoble sur
l'agriculture qui se fait à bretenière
et à celui qui suit avec les startups
sur les biotechnologies aux côtés
derrière en co design on voit construire
il ya le parc valmy qui se développe
donc tout ça fait de l'activité il faut
du rayonnement que dijon rayonne pour
attirer aussi et on est toujours bien
classé dijon est bien classé au niveau
national meilleure ville à vivre pour
les étudiants une école super de
commerce qui fonctionne universités qui
se développe voilà agrosup bon et puis
il ya le dynamisme aussi alors on attend
désormais un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
mais je vous propose son lot d'écouter
une jeune dijonnais c'est intéressant ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle dit c'est arnaud
lefebvre et daniel vaccin qui l'ont
rencontré vers le lac kir aujourd'hui
dijon est une ville très touristique est
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est que la
ville de dijon ne fait rien pour
promouvoir le tourisme
typiquement
les magasins et beaucoup de monuments
etc qui sont fermés le dimanche à dijon
je trouve ça assez inadmissible quand on
prend une ville comme bone par exemple
où effectivement c'est très développé je
voudrais comprendre pourquoi la
politique de la ville n'est pas
justement de développer le tourisme
notamment le dimanche
bon en résumé cette jeune femme elle dit
que la dijon ressemble à une petite
ville de province le dimanche garder
bonne elle parle de gone
oui mais dijon est une grande ville
dijon et demi de promesses le dimanche
la presse coface mais c'est ce qu'elle
dit à dijon le dimanche les musées sont
ouverts le musée des beaux-arts est
ouvert moi je peux pas faire ouvrir les
commerces le dimanche est donc dans
beaucoup de grandes villes en france
c'est comme ça les commerces sont fermés
le dimanche moi j'appelle les
commerçants n'a pas que le dimanche il
suffit de voir le samedi à être ouverts
entre midi et deux à vendre leur ville
beaucoup le font d'ailleurs ils ont d
enseigne attractive
je suis je suis pas d'accord avec cette
personne là beaucoup plus de touristes
n'aient jamais eu à dijon on bat les
records de fréquentation on a fait un
circuit touristique mais peut-être cette
jeune personne ne connaît pas tout ce
qui se fait sur dijon donc j'invite à
venir me voir à la mairie pillée et puis
je ferai le tour avec elle il ya
sûrement des choses à corriger améliorée
bien évidemment c'est bien quand les
gens ont des idées mais il faut pas
critiquer il faut aussi fournir des
idées et la cité de la gastronomie ça va
être un pas important c'est vous qui en
parler je voulais pas encore parce que
j'adore il va y avoir un jour un
programme à présenter ouais et donc mais
la city la gastronomie l'inscription au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco tout ça a
fait rayonner la ville regardez le musée
des beaux-arts depuis qu'il a été refait
et ça va se poursuivre il attire
énormément recommandations normalement
demain et et j'oublie le muséum jardin
des sciences c'est plus de cent mille
visiteurs on en décompte depuis le début
de l'année et puis pour l'attractivité
vous avez en compagnie de belles
personnes ces sept derniers jours les
candidates à l'élection de miss france a
particip vraiment réellement ce genre de
choses à l'attractivité d'une ville oui
bien sur l'attractivité au développement
économique vous savez c'est beaucoup de
nuitées beaucoup de restaurants beaucoup
d'image
service donc tout ça donne du dynamisme
à la ville et puis c'est une occasion
pour les dijonnais sont fiers de montrer
leur ville comment elle est belle
préserver vivant accueillante il suffit
d'ailleurs de leur demander aux miss
elle trouve la ville formidable un mot
sur la fiscalité vous avez choisi cette
année de ne pas trop augmenter de les
impôts mais les augmenter quand même de
2 1% alors jeté de faire hurler les
téléspectateurs mais la ville est
endettée pourquoi ne pas augmenter plus
c'est parce qu'il ya l approche des
élections non la grosse augmentation
c'était le conseil général vous l'avez
vu l'année dernière cette année enfin 8
me en 2013 excusez moi
j'ai un budget en 2013 de cossé général
a augmenté les impôts fonciers de si on
compte les bases de 13 80 % rendez
compte ce que ça veut dire pour les
habitants - on m'avait dit vous
augmentez les impôts pour le tram vous
allez augmenter c'est un euro c'est un
euro là où ses 85 euros du conseil
général c'est un euro et donc oui je le
vois tes doigts pour cent il ya
plusieurs stratégies beaucoup de d'élus
maires ou présidents de conseils
généraux ils disent on n'augmentera pas
les impôts dès l'élection passée il
augmente énormément les impôts je prends
l'engagement on votera ses taux je
prends l'engagement de ne pas augmenter
les impôts de plus de 1% l'année
prochaine que l'année prochaine et
l'inflation chaque année l'inflation
parce que si on n'augmente pas les
impôts du niveau de l'inflation la ville
s'appauvrit et je peux pas je ne peux
pas la laisser s'appauvrir parce que si
elle s'appauvrit ses services publics en
moins c'est des crèches en moins c'est
de l'accueillant - donc ça je ne peux
pas et où salon des services de
restauration scolaire formidable et à
plus de 7800 personnes jeunes qui
l'utilisent on a des des centres de
loisirs qui qui explosent en
fréquentation la ville le centre elle
assume beaucoup de charges de centralité
je regrette qu'elle soit pas plus céder
encore c'est normal c'est mr des gens
qui parlent
on est obligé de passer question par
question parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
questions et notamment sur la sécurité
on entend beaucoup d'adversaires un là
dessus comme quoi la ville serait
dangereuse vous avez mis en place d'un
réseau de caméras de surveillance vous
en êtes satisfait ce que ça remplace
vraiment les policiers les criirad
soleil ça aide mais ça remplace pas
vraiment en place pas vraiment
ça aide bien sûr ça aide ça permis soit
d'arrêter d'empêcher des agressions soin
de résoudre des problèmes et puis on va
continuer avec des caméras mobiles de
vidéosurveillance ça c'est très pratique
vidéoprotection devrais je dire ça c'est
très bien ça permet par exemple on en a
mis avenue du lac à la fontaine d'ouche
ça fait diminuer la vitesse des voitures
qui étaient très dangereuse donc on va
continuer dijoux est une des villes les
plus sûres de france des grandes villes
les plus sûres de france
j'ai entendu des formulations de
certains candidats qui à moi me font
peur parce que si on a peur d'être en
ville alors faut rester à la comprennent
je ne vois pas que de qui voudra real a
vous allez commencer quand votre
compagne
le coach la campagne doit se lancer
c'est à dire accepter avons lancé déjà
ah oui mais bon les gens doivent je suis
maire je travaille avec mon équipe
encore beaucoup de dossiers faut
préparer le budget ça c'est la radio
classique oui c'est vrai mais je suis
mère donc je fais mon travail de maire
pour le moment j'essaie de m'occuper
donc je suis pas encore ça commencera à
rentrer dans la tête des divisions fin
janvier en fin janvier voilà ça laisse
peu de temps mais voilà mais c'est bien
vous savez les gens sont pas dans
l'élection pour le moment ils sont
plutôt dans ça va être les illuminations
et sont plutôt les fêtes de noël après
il ya les voeux après les voeux après
les voeux un trait vous aviez déjà un
lien toutes les tendances 1 les verts
ont déjà des qui partent avec vous le
modem ça veut dire que l'équipe tour où
elle va être la même que celle qui
gérait la ville actuellement si jamais
vous êtes réélu bien évident bien sûr
oui je présenterai une liste ou y aura
bien sûr beaucoup de renouvellement de
personnalité mais avec les mêmes forces
mais oui le même rassemblement et est
effectué de la gauche du mouvement
progressiste de robert hue jusqu'au
modem oui ça c'est celle arc en ciel
c'est l'avenir de dijon c'est la couleur
art français comment vous regardez la
lutte fratricide d'en face entre alain
houpert emmanuel hamez chose ça vous
intéresse non non sincèrement non non ce
que je leur demande aux deux cdh arrêter
de dénigrer la ville faut pas dénigrer
une vie quand on est candidat dans une
ville ça c'est faux aimait sa ville
voilà comme on peut aimer son village
comme on peut aimer son village il faut
aimer sa ville il faut aimer dijon
c'est une ville qui est tellement belle
ces voix là on peut améliorer les choses
moi je dis pas que tout est parfait dans
la ville on pourrait dire il faudrait
faire un peu plus si un peu plus ça vous
n'avez pas fait assez ça mais dire les
choses comme j'ai peur la ville endettée
toutes ces choses qui sont fausses
vraiment le fn qui n'était pas présent
2008 sera donc là on a vu son ca thème
d'alice tout à l'heure on sent le montée
du fn dans le pays mais à dijon ça ne
vous inquiète pas plus que ça non j'ai
j'ai vraiment quasi
physiquement idéologie une aversion pour
cette formation je le dis comme ça elle
a gardé ses fondamentaux
de rejet de l'autre de l'étranger malgré
les visages poupins qui peuvent se
donner comme tête de liste le fond de
fait on le voit bien chez ceux qui
quittent le fn et puis quelque chose à
savoir quand le fn gère une ville la
ville trépasse chaque fois bien gérer
une ville ils l'ont laissé dans un état
lamentable
donc c'est pas des gens sérieux c'est
que c'est pas sérieux donc 6 apporte la
haine le rejet de l'autre nous on veut
une ville j'allais dire d'amour
d'échangés de mixité voilà alors il y
aura peut-être aussi d'autres candidats
il y en a notamment acquis essaye de
faire beaucoup parler de lui en ce
moment où il n'était pas allé jusqu'au
bout en 2008 on verra s'il va jusqu'au
bout en 2013 est ce que vous craignez
cette multiplicité des candidats ou est
ce que vous vous dites non non je suis
confiant je suis serein non je fais je
veux faire les choses sérieusement avec
mon équipe mais moi je suis très
respectueux de tout le monde jeunes
agréé serais je ne critiquerai personne
je vais faire nous allons faire notre
chemin sans s'occuper des autres refaire
nos propositions va montrer notre bilan
je crois que tout le monde se se plaît
reconnaître qu'il est qu'il est bon je
peux dire il est formidable quoique je
le pense un peu mais il est bon et puis
on fera des projets et puis les
dijonnais jugeront y aura des meetings
oui oui on veut je serai plein de
plaindre réunion publique j'ai prévu je
crois oui j'ai commencé à passer quand
même mais bah oui parce que février mars
ça va bientôt être là je suis prévu 40 e
réunion publique où est donc il va du
programme oui pour présenter le
programme pour pour dire aux gens c'est
pas tout de dire que cette liste que je
vais conduire à gagner il faut que les
gens se mobilisent il faut que ils
viennent voter et donc ça va être une
campagne de mobilisation
merci de vous car françois rebsamen on
aura l'occasion évidemment de revenir
sur les élections à dijon d'ici le mois
de mars je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
voir ou revoir cette émission sur
internet bourgogne point france 3 point
fr merci de votre fidélité et très bel
après-midi à tous